[Music]
I love what you're wearing this is
incredible yeah put it together
I coordinated with the blue shoes and
stuff okay they want to be clocks white
doctors wear these
wait doctors wear those and they draw
Volvos
okay all right on a watch so I'm
trustworthy today
it works in court okay
laughs
[Applause]
what are you looking over there for
those dudes those that's that's
the band that's the band no the outfit
yeah that's nice hey let me ask you
something go ahead ask me okay
very very you've been in New York all
winter and and here in La we hear it's
like the toughest worst winter ever tell
us if it's true yeah in New York on the
East Coast yeah so we me and my lady we
appreciate being out here in this
weather right now because it snowed like
150 times in New York man on East Coast
it was like somebody had spilled over
God's cocaine you know
on the west side
good cocaine they sell it in front of
Barbara Walters
some dude going to cop yeah so that was
that much snow there was a lot yeah yeah
but it didn't stop you from having fun
I'm told that you went to your first
Fashion Show recently yeah it was fun
man you know all the models and stuff so
I whipped out my belly and when I did
laughs
that right there is a mating call
that's kind of running when I did this
tingling
that's your mating call I don't have
biscuits I got a loaf of bread
fantastic so you hit that and the models
go crazy that's a mating core you just
like seeing me do that does your yeah
does your can I make a promo that got to
make the promos yeah
absolutely tune in tonight Conan's got
this
wait a minute I'm curious is your does
your does your wife does she like the
belly does she like it when you spank
that Bell I hope she do yes
she loves it because she's awesome she's
a model and she got I'm losing weight
now
yeah you can tell I'm losing weight yes
if you look closely you see the shadow
of an AB right there
you see it
[Applause]
hey I thought did you count the stretch
mark I counted the stretch marks my lady
doesn't count sheep when she go to sleep
she counts my stretch mark so she likes
you you guys you guys have a good
physical relationship yeah it's a
delicate dance thank you
this is a delicate day yes
I have to be careful what I have to be
careful we just made a baby yeah
that's good you mean like backstage yeah
yeah oh wow
he's back there right now peeing on a
stick
we always give the kiss pregnancy tests
I told you before that's my my hobby and
the summer I do karate and get girls
pregnant
okay
[Laughter]
the greatest fear
it's counting money I'm taking a dump
and having sex
in that order
you okay you're coughing there
thank you
he asked me was I okay while I was
coughing
[Laughter]